[Music]
melissa joins us up next in san diego
melissa welcome to the show
hi thank you so much for taking my call
sure
um so my question is so my dad has a
paid off house that's worth
approximately 1.4 million dollars
he's thinking that he's going to have a
forced retirement possibly in the next
coming weeks to months
in his retirement my dad would not be
able to afford the property taxes and
the upkeep to remain in this property
and my dad has done a lot with the
property and he doesn't want to lose it
outside of the family
and my husband and i just had twin boys
which are now 10 months old
and my dad has recently proposed the
idea of
allowing us to take over the house
and building a granny flat on the
property
that he would live in
my husband and i own a house and we owe
approximately 199 000 on our house in
the current market we're estimating to
get approximately 525 000
for our house which would net us
approximately 300 000
which we would use to fund the build for
the granny flat on his property that he
would live in
and my dad recently got an estimate for
the new builds that would be
approximately three hundred and forty
thousand dollars
so since the numbers are so close we
were wondering if it would be a smart
idea to get a construction loan to fund
the rest of the project
our expenses at my dad's house that we'd
be moving into are approximately 400
more per month
than the house we're currently living in
and that's just with extras such as like
pool maintenance landscaper that kind of
thing
um and this is a way for our family to
move into a bigger residence without
having much of an increase
melissa it feels like this is a recipe
for disaster and resentment because you
don't own the house and you're going to
put 300 000 in for him to live in it
while you pay all these extra
maintenance fees
what's the plan for ownership
we would have to sit down and and that's
like all the legalities but basically i
mean he owns the house outright so it
just needs i think he needs to sell this
house downsize and you guys live your
life and move on yeah that just feels
like the best plan for
relationally and financially
and i got to tell you a big question
mark for me melissa was uh 340 000
for us for a place for him to live on
the property he didn't need that much
space
i understand the cost yeah i mean i
understand it's expensive to build
anything but he don't need that big of a
place so that was a big red flag on top
of everything else
okay
and you're saying he's going to be
retiring does he have money out because
he's that doesn't free up any cash flow
for him really other than what you're
adding to it
yeah no he would just be living off of
the retirement of what he has but like i
said just with with the way that the
market is here the like the price to
move anywhere else would be
you know almost as expensive because he
owns the house outright he has like the
solar panels but he doesn't really pay
much of an electrical staying in the
house because of solar panels though i
mean i just want him to make could he
get a place for 800 900 000 is he on his
own
no it's him and my stepmom and then my
sister as well she's just finishing up
the last couple years of high school
yeah but they don't need all the space
is what you're saying it's a giant house
it sounds like correct yeah and then
we're eventually going to be having to
move up in-house in a couple years so my
husband and i were thinking we would
move in up in house in a couple years
the problem is you're at the whim of of
his decisions with his property after
you've put in 340 000 dollars
so that just feels like it's gonna get
messy
okay even if we like sat down and got
like if we were to end up selling the
house we would always leave with the
amount that we put in
potentially but even then that's that's
not an appreciating asset i'd rather you
get in a house where the house is
increasing in value instead of you just
getting your piece back
what happens what happens to the estate
when he passes i'm assuming he's thought
through this and has got this in writing
yes
yeah yes who gets that
it's my sister and i that we would be
splitting
basically his assets
which to split it you guys would need to
sell it to get money correct
yeah or he mean he has other other
investments outside of the home he has
his retirement and some other stocks and
and stuff like that that he has so it's
just really messy melissa do you feel it
i mean i think without
that
it's hard to let go because i mean like
i said we're thinking of moving into a
bigger house and we can like
have a five bucks because what the house
that we live in now is only twelve
hundred square feet
and that's my name and our two boys we
would eventually move into something
bigger
and if we can move into a bigger house
yeah but you're moving into a place with
family members
now we're all one big happy family
[Music]
are you guys dead free
uh no we have uh well obviously we have
the house and then we have um sixty
thousand dollars on a student loan okay
here's my plan for do you have an
emergency fund or savings
yeah
okay well the baby steps would tell you
let's throw all the money into debt
except four thousand dollars let's clean
up this uh student loan let's get the
fully funded emergency fund then let's
start saving up for our next house so
that's what i would be doing and maybe
you could put 400 down once you sell
this house and get a 700 000 house that
would be more suitable for your family
so i'm gonna run my own path i'm not
gonna mess with the whole family estate
piece it just feels too messy that's
just my take appreciate the call